wir sind unterwegs mit circa einem
presse auf der ukrainischen armee nur in
seiner begleitung dürfen wir in der
altstadt von odessa filmen auch die
menschen die hier leben müssen ihren
ausweis vorzeigen wenn sie zu ihren
wohnungen wollen es herrscht angst vor
feindlichen agenten die wahrscheinlich
längst in der stadt sind deshalb
kontrollieren die soldaten jeden leben
im ausnahmezustand
mit dem manche nicht klarkommen und doch
müssen eine ältere dame die ihre papiere
nicht findet ein anderer der sie
vergessen hat auch die jungen soldaten
manchmal überfordert jeden tag steht
auch ilja hier alle vier stunden ist
schichtwechsel der 23-jährige war
übersetzer jetzt kämpft er für sein land
eine perspektive ist das system bleibt
auf jeden fall also wie gesagt ich bin
mir ziemlich sicher in den jungs in den
ganzen leuten die hier stehen ich glaube
die werden in die stadt werden die
niemanden freilassen
auch unter einsatz seines lebens auch
hinter uns das waren deswegen
wir verteidigen unser land wir
verteidigen uns regt zu sein wir wollen
das und wir stehen dafür
besser die drittgrößte stadt der ukraine
größte hafenstadt des landes und damit
strategisch enorm wichtig das nächste
ziel in diesem krieg viele befürchten
dass die russische marine oder von der
see aus unter beschuss nehmen und mit
soldaten und kriegsgerät direkt an den
stränden landen könnte der flughafen
wurde schon bombardiert und russische
panzer sind nur noch 50 kilometer
entfernt
am strand von odessa füllen sie den sand
ab hunderte von freiwilligen tausende
von weißen säcken mit denen sie ihre
stadt schützen wollen david gegen den
russischen goliath der jeden tag seine
granaten und raketen über das land
hageln lässt kann das helfen es ist der
glaube der zusammenhalt und die
gewissheit aus der die ukraine in diesen
tagen ihre stärke ziehen
und nie war die nationalhymne die sie in
diesen tagen singen besser das gefühl
beschrieben dass sie alle vereint
wir werden unsere seele und unserem
körper für unsere freiheit hin geben
wie die kulisse eines hollywood
kriegsfilms so wirkt die stadt in diesen
tagen und doch es ist bitterer ernst
straßenschilder abgeklebt damit feinde
sich nicht orientieren können alte
autoreifen und sogar möbel sind zu
barrikaden geworden
was mich immer wieder beeindruckt in
diesen tagen auch hier in odessa ist der
widerstandsgeist der bevölkerung hier
der ganz normalen leute die mit ganz
einfachen mitteln so wie hier mit
solchen straßensperren glauben die
russische armee aufhalten zu können da
haben sie darauf gesprüht in einem sehr
groben spruch den ich mal so übersetzen
würde russen geht zum teufel das ist so
ein slogan dieses krieges hier geworden
wie viele geblieben sind wie viele die
stadt verlassen haben und wieviele jeden
tag aus anderen umkämpften städten
ankommen sie haben den überblick
verloren doch die meisten menschen die
meine ukrainische kollegin alexandra
hofer und ich treffen sind entschlossen
zu bleiben
ich habe angst aber ich gehe nirgendwo
hin ich bin allein ich weiß gar nicht
wohin ich gehen sollte ich habe hier
mein leben verbracht ich bleibe hier
der gourmet tempel wo es sonst aperol
spritz und odessa pizza gab bis zum
hilfszentrum geworden indem sie pakete
für soldaten und flüchtlinge packen war
mit decken essen wasser und kleidung
alles wird gebraucht und organisieren
können die ukraine das haben sie schon
oft in diesem krieg gezeigt
inge hat als rechtsanwältin gearbeitet
bis auch sie von einem tag auf den
anderen aus dem gewohnten leben geworfen
wurde eine junge frau die entschlossen
ist zu kämpfen gegen die soldaten aus
dem nachbarland das nun zum feind
geworden ist
ihnen ist nichts heilig sie werden alles
tun um uns zu zerstören und zu töten uns
zu ruinieren das ist ihre aufgabe
deshalb ja es könnte sein aber wir
versuchen jetzt alles um uns auf ihre
besatzung vorzubereiten auf ihren
einmarsch ihnen einen guten kampf zu
liefern sie zu stoppen und nicht zu
erlauben in unsere stadt zu kommen die
wir so lieben
anders als mario pol hf und auch kiew
ist odessa eine bedeutende
kulturmetropole und urlaubsort mildes
klima lockere lebensart die berühmte
potemkin showtreppe vielleicht die
berühmteste der welt wahrzeichen der
stadt das denkmal des alten gouverneurs
richelieu haben sie hinter sandsäcken
verborgen doch die sind jetzt mangelware
man kann ja nicht die ganze stadt zu
sichern
die stadt odessa ist ja ein
sehnsuchtsort auch für russen übrigens
und menschen aus aller welt eine
wunderschöne altstadt man kann das hier
im hintergrund sehen wir kommen da nicht
mehr ran weil alles abgesperrt ist
dieses tolle opernhaus diese
wunderschönen alten bauten es tut mir in
der seele weh mir auch noch vorzustellen
dass sie vielleicht in diesem krieg
zerstört werden könnten
auch die geschäfte haben sie verriegelt
und zugenagelt wer braucht in diesen
tagen schon markenklamotten alkohol ist
verboten und die zahlreichen bars und
sex clubs der stadt dienen jetzt als
luftschutzkeller oder schlafräume für
die soldaten
die offenbar ist eine der wenigen die
noch geöffnet sind hier gibt es immer
noch latte macchiato und cappuccino
doch ansonsten ist von normalität hier
nichts mehr zu spüren die schrecklichen
bilder aus mario pohl aus hartz iv auch
hier das wichtigste thema ich treffe
eine gruppe von männern aus der
protestantischen kirchengemeinde sie
haben am morgen noch versucht hilfsgüter
in die umliegenden dörfer zu bringen
doch sie sind gescheitert nicht
durchgekommen pasta witali ist empört
dort leiden die zivilisten denn die
russischen soldaten sind terroristen ja
sie sind echt terroristen
sie vernichten die friedliche
bevölkerung zu terrorisieren
plündern das ist schrecklich
wir wollten dorthin und humanitäre hilfe
leisten aber wir konnten nicht sie
beschießen zivilisten auch auf den
autobahnen
auch wenn der krieg hier noch nicht
angekommen ist auch aus odessa fliehen
sie immer noch fahren züge raus aus der
stadt und wie auf so vielen bahngleisen
an so vielen orten in der ukraine auch
hier menschen die nur das notwendigste
packen konnten kinder die abschied
nehmen müssen familien die
auseinandergerissen werden
auch elia musste seine eltern und seine
freundin zurücklassen es ist ungewiss
wie lange er hier bleiben wird ungewiss
ob und wann er jemals in sein altes
leben zurückkehren wird er ist ein
kämpfertyp er nachdenklich deshalb
möchte ich von ihm wissen wie er die
lage sieht ist das denn wirklich so dass
der rückhalt von der bevölkerung so
stark ist will man immer sagt es ist das
beste das ja ich fühle dass auf jeden
fall die leute bringen auf jeden fall
warme sachen vorbei was essen was zu
trinken also alles
und dann müssen wir unsere dreharbeiten
ganz plötzlich unterbrechen die sirenen
heulen
das ist jetzt fliegeralarm und der
presseoffizier hat uns gesagt wir müssen
jetzt hier schnell in einen keller gehen
alle zusammen er ist schon mal
vorgegangen wir müssen jetzt auch gleich
rein
ein stripclub als luftschutzkeller
hier warten wir gemeinsam auf entwarnung
checken unsere handys nach nachrichten
keiner weiß was wirklich passiert
dann nach 20 minuten dürfen wir wieder
raus und sind für einen moment
erleichtert aber lange nicht erlöst